Faut pas que je pleure.
Valery, je t’aime très fort.
Et maintenant,
on est réunies,
pour toute la vie.
Salut, c’est Juliette !
Imagine que tu vis toute ta vie
en pensant que
tu es enfant unique,
et un jour, tu découvres que t’as un frère ou une sœur
ou même un parent
dont tu ignorais
totalement l’existence.
Ça ressemble à une histoire qui n’existe que dans les films,
mais récemment,
j’ai lancé une messagerie
pour voir si ça touchait beaucoup de monde,
et en fait, vous êtes assez nombreux à avoir vécu ça.
En fait, j’ai lancé
cette messagerie
parce qu’il y a
quelques semaines,
j’ai reçu un message sur Insta qui m’a beaucoup touchée.
Évidemment
que ça m’a intéressée !
J’avais super envie de filmer l’histoire de ces deux sœurs
qui ne se connaissaient pas
et assister à leur toute première rencontre.
Du coup,
j’ai répondu à Sandrine,
et aujourd’hui, je vais vous raconter son histoire.
Ça va casser !
Hein, ça va casser ?
- T’attends combien de personnes, alors, à peu près ?
- 36.
Naïa, Emma,
Lïna…
Sydney, s’ils sont là,
Lindsey, si elle est là,
Ophelye, si elle est là, euh… Noemye, si elle est là.
Sandrine organise une fête
pour fêter l’anniversaire
de sa fille.
Elle a fait une grande liste d’invités,
mais elle espère surtout la présence d'une invitée
super importante :
sa grande sœur, qu’elle n’a encore jamais rencontrée.
En fait, le truc,
c’est qu’elle ne sait pas
quand sa sœur va venir.
C’est le stress !
- Non, il ne faut pas stresser,
il faut prendre ça…
Il faut prendre les choses comme elles viennent.
C’est un beau moment
à passer,
c’est bien pour toi,
c’est bien pour...
pour tout le monde, pour tes enfants, pour tout le monde.
Tu restes en bas, Lïna !
Tu vas être toute seule, Lïna !
Donc là, je t’explique, Naïa.
- Oui.
- Oh, waouh !
- Tu vas laisser ton lit, Naïa ?
Et toi, tu as le choix :
soit tu dors avec
papa et maman,
dans la chambre,
dans un lit parapluie,
soit tu dors avec
tes cousines.
- Je dors avec
mes cousines !
- J’en étais sûre !
- C’est normal,
c’est une enfant.
- Et du coup, tata Valery,
tu sais qui c’est, alors ?
C’est qui tata Valery ?
C’est la sœur de…
- Maman !
- Voilà !
Sandrine a 26 ans,
et elle est née dans
une famille de parents
toxicomanes.
À ses 6 mois,
elle est placée
en famille d’accueil,
car ses parents
ne savent pas s’occuper d’elle.
Sa mère décède
d’une overdose
peu de temps
après son placement.
En famille d'accueil, donc,
j’étais chez M. et Mme ***
Ça se passait très, très bien.
Quand tu es
en famille d’accueil,
ta famille d'accueil
a tout à fait le droit
de te remettre dans
une autre famille d’accueil
quand ils partent
en vacances.
Moi, la chance que j’ai eue,
c’est que je partais
en vacances avec
ma famille d’accueil.
Partout où ils allaient,
je les suivais.
Son père meurt
quand elle a 8 ans,
et Sandrine
devient orpheline.
Du coup, sa famille d’accueil décide de l’adopter.
Elle avance dans la vie,
se marie et a deux enfants.
Tout se passe bien jusqu’au moment où elle découvre
qu’elle a une maladie génétique.
Du coup,
elle décide d’aller
retrouver son dossier
auprès des services sociaux.
Donc, on est arrivés
à la DDASS.
J’arrive dans le bureau,
blanc.
Il y avait qu’un bureau, blanc.
"Sandrine, assieds-toi."
Et là, elle me dit :
"Vous êtes au courant
de quoi de votre passé ?"
Je dis : "Je suis au courant
que j’ai un frère."
"Mais vous n’êtes
pas au courant
que vous avez une sœur
qui vous recherche
depuis 26 ans ?"
Là, j'étais…
vidée.
Il n’y avait
plus rien qui sortait.
Je dis : "Bah, non…
je ne suis au courant
de rien du tout."
Grosse info !
Sandrine découvre
que son père
a eu un enfant
avec une autre femme,
et que cette fille,
du coup, sa sœur,
à 17 ans de plus qu’elle.
Ce qu’il faut savoir,
c’est que dans ce dossier
des services sociaux,
il y a des dizaines de lettres
que sa sœur lui a écrites
au fil des années
que Sandrine
n’a jamais reçues.
Elle m'a donné le dossier,
elle m'a montré les lettres
que ma sœur m’avait écrites,
et je n’en revenais pas.
J’ai essayé de l’appeler sur le numéro qui était sur la lettre.
Bien évidemment,
depuis ce temps-là,
le numéro n’existait plus.
J’ai pris mon téléphone,
j'ai regardé sur Facebook.
Mais ce qui m’a sauvée,
c’est que son prénom
est avec un Y.
Valery avec un Y.
Il n’y en a pas beaucoup.
Et j’ai vu sa photo.
Mon cousin, il me dit :
"Mais c’est peut-être pas elle,
il y en a peut-être beaucoup.”
J’ai dit : "Non, c’est elle."
18 février.
- Et quand
t’as reçu ce message,
tu t'es sentie comment ?
Ça s’est passé comment ?
- Bah, déjà, je n’y croyais pas.
Je me suis dit : “C’est pas possible.”
- C’est vrai ?
C’était magique.
J’en dormais plus, c’était…
Je me suis dit : "Au bout de 26 ans, retrouver ma sœur !"
Pour moi, c’était...
c’était impossible,
je ne la retrouverais jamais.
Au décès de son père,
Valery apprend
qu’elle a une sœur.
À ce moment-là, elle a 25 ans,
et a déjà trois enfants.
Pendant des années,
elle cherche à entrer en contact avec sa sœur,
d’abord via des lettres,
et ensuite, en cherchant
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Mais comme Sandrine ne porte plus le nom de son père,
impossible de la retrouver.
Le seul visage que j’avais, c’était d’une photo,
une photo quand j’ai vidé l’appartement de mon père
parce qu’il fallait que je vide son appartement.
Donc, c’est là que
j’ai vu qu’elle existait.
Il y avait son lit,
il y avait tout, quoi.
Donc, je m'étais mis d’accord avec les services sociaux,
la DDASS, tout, pour qu’en fait, on puisse créer des liens,
se rencontrer
de temps en temps,
enfin,
lui expliquer
que j’étais sa sœur et tout,
que je pouvais pas l’enlever, comme ça,
du jour au lendemain.
Et en fait, je n’ai jamais eu
de suite.
Et quand j’ai demandé
à avoir des contacts,
on n’a jamais voulu
me donner de contact.
Je n’avais pas le droit de prendre contact avec elle.
Strictement rien, quoi.
Tu veux que je la mette
dans la valise, ça, maman ?
- Hein ?
- Tu veux que je mette ça
dans la valise ?
- Oui, attends.
Ça…
Bon, il fait quel temps, là-bas ?
- Très chaud !
- Froid.
- Mais non, il ne fait pas froid.
Ils nous ont annoncé chaud !
Voilà.
Ça, tu mets déjà ça
dans la valise.
Ça, c’est à toi, Ophélie ?
- Et du coup, comment
vous avez appris
que vous aviez
une autre tante ?
- Par maman.
Tata a envoyé le premier message à maman…
- Elles ont parlé, je pense...
Elle a pas dormi
de la nuit, quoi.
- Elle a posé des questions
pour savoir si c’était
sa vraie sœur ou non.
- Et après, elle nous l’a dit quand elle était sûre d’elle !
- Et après, elles ont fait un appel en visio pour se voir.
La première fois,
elle était toute gênée !
- Eh bien, sachez que moi,
je l’ai appris avant vous !
Les deux sœurs se parlent tous les jours
depuis plusieurs mois,
mais elles ne se sont encore jamais rencontrées.
Sandrine sait que Valery
va venir lui rendre visite
à un moment en juin,
mais elle ne sait pas exactement quand.
Valery décide de partir avec sa famille quelques jours
avant la fête
pour lui faire la surprise.
Pour filmer leur trajet
du sud jusqu’en Bretagne,
je leur passe
une petite caméra.
Et tu vois, quand il y a
la petite lumière rouge ?
- Ah, c’est que ça filme !
- Exactement.
Et si tu veux te filmer toi,
tu dois juste tourner...
Voilà, exactement.
Ouais, et maintenant,
tu peux…
- Ah non, ça nous filme nous !
- Non, mais du coup,
tu peux te regarder,
tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
- Ah oui !
Voilà ! C’est parti
pour la Bretagne.
- Let’s go!
Les enfants,
vous êtes bien chargés ?
- Oui !
- C’est bon ?
- Le mari ?
- On est là !
- On est dans la zone !
- On décolle, allez !
Coucou ! Ça va ?
- Alors ?
Je ne sais pas
quand elle arrive.
Ça commence à me gaver, cette histoire !
Tic-tac !
- Yoan, toi, tu sais quand
ils arrivent ?
- Ouais !
- On sait tous !
- Voilà, c’est tout.
- Tout le monde sait,
sauf Sandrine.
- C’est ça.
Et ça, c'est beau.
Là, c’est dimanche, on rigole, on rigole, on fait la fête,
mais moi, j’ai mon cœur
qui va lâcher, en fait,
parce que ma fille, 1 an,
ma sœur…
- Mais j'espère que ton cœur ne va pas lâcher avant !
- Vous aussi,
vous êtes stressés ?
- Ah, bah, là, c’est une sacrée histoire quand même, hein.
Bah, ça fait 10 ans
qu’on est ensemble.
Ça fait 10 ans qu’on discute
de tes racines
et tout ça, tu vois ?
Et au final, du coup,
le fait d’avoir quelque chose de concret, maintenant,
avec des vraies personnes,
avec des vrais visages à mettre derrière,
et pas juste des noms et des noms de famille et tout ça,
c’est vrai que c’est assez fou et c’est chouette.
Et puis, même pour moi,
tu vois, c’est...
c’est une belle famille
que je n’avais pas,
et puis, du coup,
qui vient là, comme ça.
Non, c’est cool.
- Après, voilà,
à moi d’apprendre
à avoir une sœur.
C’est pas évidemment, hein,
ce que c’est d’avoir une sœur.
Les enfants dorment.
Petit arrêt.
La route est interminable.
On n’en peut plus.
On est au bout de notre vie !
Mais je pourrai mettre
mes lunettes de soleil ?
- Non.
- Tu peux me mettre un chapeau ?
- Mais Naïa, tu ne vas pas
à la plage,
tu vas à l’école !
- C’est l’école, chérie !
Et voilà !
Nous arrivons sur la fin.
Tic-tac, tic-tac...
Tu dis au revoir ?
- Au revoir !
Sandrine, on arrive !
Ça va ?
- Oui, et vous ?
- Ouais !
- J’ai plus rien à faire.
- T’as plus rien à faire,
là, c’est bon  ?
- Jusqu’à 1 h, hier soir.
- Nickel !
- Quoi ?
- Oh, putain !
- Non !
OK, petite pause
dans l’histoire.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué,
mais avec le micro-cravate,
on entend le battement hyper rapide de leur cœur !
Ça va pas, hein !
Et tu fais la même taille
que moi, effectivement !
- Oui, on est petites !
Ça, on le tient du père.
- Ah, bah, ça...
ça, c’est sûr !
La mère, j’en sais rien,
mais alors, le père !
Oh, la vache !
Vous allez me prendre
pour une folle,
mais quand je vous ai connus,
quand j’ai su
que vous étiez là, quoi,
j’ai tout noté, là,
les anniversaires !
- Mais non !
- J'ai tout noté !
Et tous les jours, je regarde.
“Y a pas un anniversaire,
ce mois-ci ?
Ah non, c’est bon !”
Je n’ai pas parlé
de mon passé.
J’en parlais comme ça,
mais pour moi,
j’étais toute seule,
puis j'avançais toute seule,
quoi, tu vois ?
Après, tu peux te dire que
t’es tranquille dans ta tête,
malgré ces 26 ans
qu’on s’est… Voilà.
J’ai toujours été bien
avec eux.
Ils m’ont sortie de la merde.
Sans eux, je ne serais plus là, honnêtement.
Après, c’est fait, c’est fait.
On ne pourra pas
revenir en arrière.
Est-ce que ça te met en colère
de savoir qu’on t’a empêchée de voir quelqu'un qui t’aimait
pendant 26 ans ?
- Oui.
Je suis beaucoup
en colère, parce que
c’est du mensonge.
En fin de compte, on a grandi dans le mensonge.
Je trouve que c'est
du grand n’importe quoi
le fait qu'on ne nous dise pas, qu’on nous cache les choses.
Plus on le dit jeune,
mieux c’est,
parce qu'après, ça fait beaucoup de dégâts.
Bon, je les ai quand même laissées tranquilles
pendant le reste de l'après-midi et le lendemain,
pour qu’elles puissent
se retrouver un peu
après 26 ans.
Mais ensuite,
je les ai rejoints
pour la célébration
de l’anniversaire.
Depuis 18 ans,
Valery recherche des réponses à ses questions,
et c’est surtout en rencontrant le père adoptif de Sandrine
qu’elle espère en obtenir.
Je pense que le seul souci qu’on a avec Sandrine,
c’est qu'en fait, on a beau poser quelques questions,
parce qu’elle essaie
de poser des questions aussi,
et qu’on n’a pas de réponse...
Et on en aura
peut-être jamais,
ou peut-être
à la suite du dossier,
quand elle recevra
le reste du dossier,
mais bon, qui traîne, malheureusement.
C’est un peu ça aussi que je veux faire comprendre
dans le reportage,
c’est que c’est pas tout facile.
Il n’y a pas une route qui va être droite jusqu’à la fin.
- Oui, c’est ça.
Maintenant, il va falloir apprendre à se reconstruire,
Brûler le passé,
ça, c'est notre objectif.
Une fois que tout sera fait, tout sera fini,
que moi je me sentirai prête, que ma sœur se sentira prête,
on enlève tout le passé.
On ne pourra pas rattraper le temps perdu, ça, c'est sûr,
mais après, je veux
qu’on me fiche la paix
avec ce passé-là.
C’est une nouvelle vie
qui commence.
Et sinon,
je vais dire
quelque chose aussi.
Je ne la vois pas... Maman ?
Il y a une phrase que
tu m’as dite il y a un mois
que j’ai retenue.
Tu m’as dit :
“Je suis très contente
que tu aies retrouvé ta famille,
parce que le jour
où je vais partir,
je sais que
tu ne seras pas seule.”
Et ça, merci beaucoup !
Et Valery ?
Je veux aussi te dire
que je t’aime très fort,
et que maintenant,
on est réunies
pour toute la vie !
Valery et Sandrine
n’ont pas toutes les réponses sur leur histoire,
mais en tout cas, aujourd’hui, elles ne se quittent plus !
Cet été,
Sandrine ira avec sa famille retrouver Valery
dans le sud pour
les vacances,
et elles sont déjà en train de faire des préparations
pour les plans de Noël.
Des histoires
comme celles-ci,
je les trouve assez ouf,
et ça me fait toujours plaisir de vous rencontrer
et de raconter vos histoires.
Sandrine, elle m’a trouvée
via, justement,
ma demande à la fin
de mes autres vidéos,
donc n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message
sur Instagram
si vous avez un sujet
que vous voulez que je traite.
Si vous voulez voir d’autres vidéos comme celle-ci,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne Brut,
et on se voit la prochaine fois !